go to Brandon Jud right now the national
border patrol council president Brandon
if we could go back to an issue I raised
earlier because it still sticks in my
craw here these these trains that get in
the United States and they have a lot of
migrants on them a lot of them were
opening it up and sharing um but does
anyone track them in other words that
particular train uh does anyone count
how many get off where they go where
they are right
now so because they they unload in
Mexico no there's there's no government
officials in Mexico counting how many
people we do have Intelligence Officers
that are trying to do the best that they
can to keep track of how many people but
there's no way to know specifically how
many people are coming to our borders
they're going to disembark that train in
Mexico the cartels will then grab them
they will they will then disperse them
um across our entire Southwest border
and then they will cross um where the
cartels want them to cross all of this
is dictated by organized crime and
organized crime is very good at at
generating a profit at getting these
people where they need to go in order to
be able to cross and and be able to make
it into the United States and some of
them get there and and get a train to do
that and in San Diego comes to mind I I
guess what confuses me though with this
whole process is uh the view we get is
that it's getting better that the
numbers are getting more stable but I
look at the numbers uh it appears just
the
opposite Neil that is as far from the
truth as as as anything these numbers
are astronomical we're apprehending more
than seven uh seven times what we should
be at at any given day yesterday is the
first day in my 26 year time of being
with the national border patrol Council
that I I I didn't see one gotway um
recorded by by the border patrol and
that's simply because we don't have the
resources in the field to detect these
people we're we're constantly stuck in
processing we're doing administrative
duties rather than enforcement duties so
yesterday we didn't even record one
gotway um which is which should be
concerning to everybody when you look at
the numbers we are way above anywhere
where where we should be but the problem
is is that this administration because
they continue to ignore it they're
setting a new Norm our Norm should be a
thousand apprehensions a day we're at
7,000 apprehensions and and that's what
the new Norm has now become and that
should be scary to everybody because we
just don't have any border patol agents
that are in the field patrolling the
Border doing what we should be to
protect the American citizens and that's
what allows the drugs to come in as well
that's why we have so many deaths in the
United States in drug overdoses you know
Brandon um what did you think of the
Chicago mayor saying this hullo over
migrants and what they're doing in
cities um is is a classic case of
right-wing extremism don't listen to the
right-wing extremist I I I think he's
all but saying you my friend are a
right-wing
extremist you know it makes me sick to
hear this rhetoric if this if mayor
Johnson truly cared about people he
would enforce the rule of law he would
go to this Administration and he he he
has a large voice in the democra party
he would tell this Administration what
they need to do is they need to start
enforcing the laws on the border they
need to stop allowing people to come
into the United States and get released
into the United States that is a
decision by this Administration if they
wanted to they could hold people in
cussy they could reimplement policies
and programs that don't allow people to
be released into United States that's
the magnet that draws people that's why
cartels are so so effective they can go
throughout the world advertise our
services tell people that all they have
to do is violate our laws and they're
still going to be released into the
United States and that's what Mayor
Johnson refuses to recognize if he would
do that this problem would go away but
we just don't have anybody from the
Democrat Party that that are in these
cities or in the White House that wants
to do what's right by the American
people and by the way save migrants
lives as well I don't see the Mexicans
doing much to to alleviate this for us
the Mexican president when he was with
Joe Biden last month was more or less
saying thank you for not building a wall
uh you know we'll work with the United
States on this we celebrate all the
Mexicans who have come to the United
States didn't discern whether they got
here legally or not so does Mexico just
talk a good game and just let us figure
this out or doesn't care whether we
figure it
out the Mexican government has no
incentive to stop what's going on when
you look at the amount of money that is
going into that country from all of
these people they have to spend money as
they're making their Journey up through
Mexico then on top of that when you look
at the the money that the criminal
cartels are making off of the
trafficking of these individuals that
money is going right back into the into
the Mexican economy when you look at at
the billions of dollars that these
cartels are generating that money is
going back into the Mexican economy the
government of Mexico has no incentive to
stop this the only reason that President
Trump was successful in getting the
Mexican Government to actually be true
border security Partners is because he's
threatened tariffs that were greater
than the amount of money that the
cartels were able to generate and bring
into the economy but as long as those
cartels are generating that money and as
long as we do not take action against
the Mexican Government for not stopping
any of the crime that is taking place
the cartels are going to continue to
rule that moneyy is going to continue to
go into the economy into the Mexican
economy and The Mexican government is
going to continue to allow it to happen
Brandon it's amazing we we keep running
around the same issue Brandon Jud the
national border patrol council president
good seeing you again my friend thank
you I'm Steve duy I'm Brian kilme and
I'm Angley aart and click here to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis